Frank Miller is a comic book artist
writer and movie director who is known
for his edgy storytelling he is one of
very few creators who has worked on
major projects both for Marvel and DC
Comics some of his most popular works
are daredevil Sin City 300 and Batman
The Dark Knight while he may have seen
his name on the cover of a comic book or
in the movie credits few people know the
story of how Frank Miller went from
being a comic book fan growing up in a
small town in Vermont to someone who has
gained international fame and fortune
and in the biographic sideo today well
we're gonna tell you all about him Frank
Miller was born in Olney Maryland on
January the 27th 1957 into a large Irish
Catholic family his mother was a nurse
and his father ran his own business as
an electrician and carpenter Frank's
family moved to Montpelier Vermont where
he grew up with his six siblings when he
was six years old Frank Miller bought
his first a Batman comic book in after
reading the comics so much that he began
drawing Batman on pieces of scrap paper
he took some of his parents typewriter
papers so that he could fold and staple
the pages together into a small comic
book he then drew his first comic and
presented it to his mother saying that
this was what he was going to do when he
grew up his father became a traveling
salesman and he would drive back and
forth between Vermont and New York City
Frank would go with him on these road
trips just so he could look through the
big comic book stores in New York and
buy all of the different titles that he
couldn't get in his small town in
Vermont for the rest of his young life
he would read comics and practice
drawing in the hopes that he could make
his dreams come true growing up his
favorite movies to watch were film noir
movies like Touch of Evil and Chinatown
these stories they always had a lot of
action with corrupt detectives and
beautiful femme fatales he especially
loved the movies that were in black and
whites because of the drama that
filmmakers were able to achieve with all
of the dark shadows on the screen over
the years he read every comic he get his
hands on he wasn't just enjoying the
stories as a fan he was analyzing both
the writing and the artwork absorbing
every little detail he would read every
new character published by marvel
including one called of a cat claws of
the cat which premiered in November of
1972 when he was 16 years old he wrote a
fan letter to Marvel Comics soon after
reading this new comic this letter was
published in issue number three in the
letter he wrote wonderful at last a
woman character with character I for one
am sick of the helpless female types
which have cluttered up comics for so
long this woman that Frank Miller was
talking about which ends up being
renamed tiger oh and what many people
have not heard of this superhero today
she would be an inspiration for how he
portrayed his female characters in the
future even though they're only
responded to his fan letter it was still
exhilarating to see his name in print
still he always knew that he wanted to
draw comics for the rest of his life and
he felt ready to leave his parents home
on one of these long road trips with his
father he packed a few extra bags with
the intention of moving to New York City
when he was only 17
all his life Frank Miller dreamed of
permanently getting out of the
countryside and he was exhilarated to be
surrounded by the city that he was so in
love with one of the first things that
he did was visit the Empire State
Building at the time there were no
screens up to prevent people from
falling over the ledge if they went to
the very top
therefore Miller was able to sit up on a
Ledge with the sketchbook ins he was
drawing the skyline he kept on sitting
on rooftops to get a sense of the city
from those angles these drawings would
eventually end up in his later comics
Miller lived in a tiny studio apartment
and he was able to use the carpentry
skills he'd learned by working at his
father's business to find gigs that
would help him pay his rent the
apartment was very small and old and
there were cockroaches and water bugs
crawling all over the place
he was motivated to work for a better
life and to try and start his career
therefore he started making appointments
and taking his drawing portfolio to
various comic book publishers around New
York he met with Joe Orlando at DC
Comics who told Miller that he was not
good enough to work for them and he
might never be his portfolio was held
together with strings and bugs that
crawled inside it at some point as we
were talking one of these pests crawled
out of my portfolio into my lap and I
could do nothing but cut my little
friends during the interview as it
squirmed and desperately fought for its
life it was not the brightest day of my
life needless to say he did not get that
job that level of constant humiliation
it would have been enough for some
people to pack
bags and move back home and for a while
it truly did seem as if Miller's dream
would never become a reality but he
never gave up with every rejection he
kept trying to improve and he went to
more and more interviews Frank Miller's
favorite artist by far with Niall Adams
who's Batman and Green Lantern comics
had made him a big superstar he had a
background in advertising so his
pictures had an elements of photo
realism with accurate Anatomy he was
looking for more of atoms as work and
trying to aspire to be like him when he
went on an interview at Marvel Comics he
actually got to meet Niall Adams and he
let him know how much he admired his
work Adams credits his daughter with his
decision to give Millar a chance
he stated obviously she felt sorry for
him because it was a skinny kid who
looked like Ichabod Crane he went on to
say that Miller's portfolio was quote
awful it was so bad my heart sunk and I
was like oh my god one of these guys
even though he harshly criticized his
work - he graciously called up one of
his friends to help Frank Miller get a
job as a storyboard artist as an
advertising firm the artwork that was
required for these kind of jobs did not
need to be as realistic as a Marvel
comic Birkins this way Miller was able
to get professional experience and get
tips from co-workers on a daily basis
now the Frank Miller was a working
artist he no longer had to struggle to
find carpentry work to pay the bills he
was drawing for a living and he was
getting better during the process but he
still wanted to do comics every time
Miller thought that maybe it improved
his art enough he would go to Neal Adams
and apply to work at Marvel again it
took a very long time to truly
understand how to improve Adams would
take Miller's drawings and place a piece
of tracing paper over the top so that he
could draw his own version showing how
to properly redraw the same image he
then pushed the copy paper towards
Miller as if to say try again after
watching Niall Adams so many times he
began to study anatomy textbooks to get
a good feeling for drawing the human
body he realized that his biggest
problem was creating accurate
proportions and understanding how
muscles and bones moved together he
would practice these tips that Adams
gave him and came back again and again
finally one day Neal Adams looked at the
drawings and picked up the phone call
his connections and to get him a job
with gold key comics Adam said whatever
you do don't say that I'm responsible
for Frank Miller I've done the same
thing for a hundred guys and nobody
responded the way Frank did
nobody advanced that quickly and I made
it hard for him if you all gone through
it you'd have gone home crying they were
publishing the comic book version of The
Twilight Zone there were very few copies
made because it wasn't an incredibly
popular comic but Frank Miller was still
over the moon because this was his
chance to get his foot in the door of
the industry he was so nervous about
doing a good job with his first paid gig
that it took him three weeks to complete
just three pages but this was just the
beginning of his career as a comic book
artist after this he started getting
small gigs at both DC and Marvel and had
truly begun his journey to success as
time went on Frank Miller had enough
professional experience under his belt
to be hired as a full-time artist and
writer at Marvel Comics for the series
daredevil Stanley and artist bill
Everett had created daredevil but Frank
Miller is responsible for the dark and
gritty hard edge that defined the
character he was able to explore New
York's Hell's Kitchen first hands and
accurately capture the essence of this
area since Miller was raised Irish
Catholic he was also able to bring a lot
of the internal struggles felt by
daredevil secret identity Matt Murdock
whose religious beliefs stopped him from
killing bad guys at that time Frank
Miller had no aspirations to make
original characters he was just thrilled
to finally have a steady job working in
the comic-book industry but it was clear
that he had a unique artistic style and
point of view he was constantly
researching by reading comics from all
over the world and he thought a lot
about how he could draw a scene to make
the reader slow down and really take
their time on each page by giving them a
visually interesting world he eventually
created the character Elektra during an
interview he explained his motivations
for creating the character stating
daredevil had a lot of girlfriends but
what about one who can kick his butt she
became the first female character who
was like the femme fatale of the old
film noir movies that he loved so much
she was beautiful and she couldn't be
trusted she was an assassin but
love Matthew Murdock created a feeling
of guilt sorry to spoil it for those of
you who don't know but we do need to
mention that Frank Miller made the
decision that Elektra had to die for her
crimes which he did at the hands of the
villain bullseye
nothing like this had ever been done in
comics before especially with such a
popular character before this most
characters continued to live on forever
even if they were villains it was dark
and he showed that he was gearing the
series towards adult readers this also
really showed that Frank cared more
about the storytelling than he did the
popularity plenty of fans they were
upset by the death of Elektra but Frank
Miller but the story first without
worrying too much about the public
opinion he was writing the story in a
way that makes sense for the life and
growth of the characters he knew that
Matt Murdock would never be able to
settle down and have a happily ever
after life with a lecturer but they were
too in love to ever leave each other so
the only way for him to move on and be
with someone else would be if electret
died
[Music]
in 1983 he left Marvel Comics to work
for DC he published a series called
Ronin which was about a samurai warrior
Frank Miller had been inspired by French
comics and Japanese manga and he
borrowed from the styles that he
discovered from both of these countries
specifically he credits lone wolf and
cub by kazuo koike as being his biggest
influence as well as the work of Jean
Gerard who goes by the pen name mobius
frank miller began working together with
an artist DC comics named Lynn Varley
who inked and colored the drawings of
Ronin they worked incredibly well
together bouncing ideas off one another
constantly she continued to do the
inking on all of his future work they
also fell in love and eventually got
married
sadly they divorced in 2005 DC loved his
work so much that they asked him to
write and draw a new Batman series at
first he actually said no because he
respected Batman as a character too much
after all it was the very first comic
that had ever read and he knew that the
character meant just as much to millions
of people around the world as he meant
to him even though he was working
full-time in the comic book industry
those feelings of self-doubt they were
still there he was afraid that he wasn't
good enough and that he might ruin
Batman
however he did keep the thought in the
back of his mind for years the character
of Batman had never aged he was
permanently 29 years old and Robin was
always this teenage sidekick he thought
to himself I'll be damned if I'm all of
them Batman and it was at this point
that he had a light bulb moment he
imagined Batman in his 50s he's older
disillusioned and grizzled and for a man
who's been dressing as a bat for so many
years he's certainly gonna have some
psychological issues his story of Batman
is far darker than any other version
that had ever come before it and this
comic was of course Batman The Dark
Knight Returns this became a huge
success and it especially resonated with
fans who had grown up with the character
the movie adaptation of The Dark Knight
in 2008 became one of the most
successful superhero stories of all time
and it's arguably the best portrayal of
Batman that has ever been made during an
interview at the Cuban School of Media
Frank Miller was asked if he preferred
daredevil or Batman he very quickly said
but Batman will always be number one in
his heart because his motivations behind
his character are beautifully simple
Batman is trying to restore order to a
world where there is none while the
Joker is trying to create chaos because
of that the story will stand the test of
time
[Applause]
after seeing success in the comic book
industry Frank Miller decided that he
wanted to move to a warmer climate so he
left New York and moved to Los Angeles
they had no intention of getting into
the movie business but one day he got a
phone call from a movie producer who
wanted to work with him on Robocop 2 & 3
since he loved the first movie he agreed
to work on the project however the
director was constantly changing Frank
Miller's script during Robocop 2 he was
on set every day wanting to be involved
what about by Robocop 3 he got so angry
at the moviemaking process he decided to
leave and never come back
during an interview he said don't be the
writer the directors got power the
screenplay is a fire hydrant with a row
of dogs waiting around the block for it
Miller played small cameo roles in
Robocop 2 & 3 and he dies in both films
after getting these small screen credits
he made cameos and some other movies too
in 1994 both Frank Miller and Stan Lee
played themselves in a movie called
jugular Winer a vampire Odyssey there is
even a scene where Stan Lee gets to kill
Frank Miller so while he got to enjoy
having fun in a campy horror film he
still began to feel jaded and he didn't
feel the same passion for his career
that he had back in New York he really
wasn't doing what he actually loved he
began to feel a lot of angst towards Los
Angeles this is what inspired him to
write Sin City in 1991 he was inspired
to make the story by a black-and-white
comic called Johnny Hazzard by Frank
Robbins and all of the film noir had
watched as a kid he sold the idea to
Dark Horse Comics he decided to not hold
back and just bought everything that he
wanted into the comic he said he wanted
it to have tough guys beautiful women
and vintage cars Sin City was released
in a series of graphic novels that are
standalone stories but they all exist in
the same universe
he continued to work on Sin City over
the next few years because it was what
he truly enjoyed doing and he was
totally satisfied with it being his one
and only project in 2003 a daredevil
movie was released starring Ben Affleck
since the character rights belonged to
Marvel Frank Miller didn't have any
creative input on the film many fans
felt that this movie did not capture the
true essence of the daredevil comics and
they wouldn't get what they were looking
for until Netflix created the original
series in 2015 starring Charlie Cox
however in an interview in 2017 Miller
said that he had not even bothered to
watch the Netflix series so he doesn't
give any
about what he personally thinks about
those adaptations ironically even though
he created the Sin City comic after
venting his frustrations with
Hollywood's and he really did not enjoy
watching adaptations of his work
all of that would circle back in 2005
when he got the opportunity to write and
direct the Sin City movie with Robert
Rodriguez at first Miller said no to the
project because Sin City was like his
baby and he had seen what Hollywood had
done to his work in the past but
Rodriguez he was a fan he understood how
important it was to portray the stories
accurately Rodriguez also gave Frank
Miller complete creative control so that
he could recreate his comics panel by
panel and frame by frame they worked on
showing these screen tests do several
different actors and they were surprised
and impressed by the work he was able to
attract a star-studded cast and even
Quentin Tarantino helps to direct the
fight scenes in the movie during an
interview about Sin City he said that he
was shocked at how much he enjoyed
working together with the actors he said
I expected the worst and they got the
best in the behind-the-scenes clips
their feeling seems to be mutual all of
the actors were really happy that they
could ask Frank Miller questions about
the characters motivations as well as
getting more depth about the overall
story since then Morra Frank Miller
stories have been adapted to both the
small and big screens
he continues to publish new comics on a
regular basis at 62 years old he is far
from retiring any time soon in 2018
Netflix order this series called cursed
which is a darker reimagining of the
King Arthur legend even though he's
still making new material he has already
reached legendary status in a lot of
ways as images define a generation today
his work has been on display in a number
of art museums including the Norman
Rockwell Museum and even the Louvre in
Paris the work of the young man who was
told that he wasn't good enough is now
next to some of the greatest artists in
the world the cherry on top of all of
this success is that Frank Miller has
made quite a lot of money - yes
estimated net worth of forty five
million dollars he earned his fortune
doing what he loved and doing it
extremely well so I really hope you
enjoyed that video if you did please do
give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week if you're looking for something
else to watch though why not check out
my other channel called top 10s we do
top 10 videos
got a bunch about comics and comic book
artists and all of that stuff so go
check out that channel there's a link
below and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]